[Musique]
il reste le monsieur Y de la politique
en référence à ces travaux sur les
chromosomes généticiens de renom figure
des démocrates du gars par le monter élu
deux fois et même repêché de justesse
par le Conseil constitutionnel il clame
qu'il ne brillera pas un nouveau mandat
mais ce proche d'Edouard Philippe entre
autres rallié à la majorité
présidentielle ne perd pas de vue
l'horizon des prochaines échéances le
député MoDem du Gard et l'invité du
grand entretien de ce dimanche en
politique Philippe Bertha bonjour
bonjour à vous merci de votre présence
et merci à vous tous de nous suivre
d'abord vous vous souvenez sans doute
pour commencer de se vif échange avec
Didier Raoult c'était le 24 juin 2020
lors de l'audition de la commission
d'enquête sur le covid-19 regardez
pourquoi n'avons pas fait des essais
cliniques dignes de ce nom dès le départ
qui aurait pu définitivement répondre
OUI ou NON l'hydroxycleroquet n'a un
effet pourquoi vous êtes-vous cantonné à
des publications que vous êtes je
connais tous vos travaux sur les riquets
de si je connais votre travaux sur les
maxi virus etc donc je connais votre
science
bien établie vous saviez très bien qu'en
publiant ces pseudo etc thérapeutique ce
pseudo et ses clinique en fait il
n'était absolument pas recevable par qui
que ce soit parce que quand on se
retrouve sur une publication à la fin
avec six patients on sait très bien que
c'est pas un essai clinique tout est
fait qui comporte plus de 1000 personnes
est un essai qui cherche à démontrer
chose qui n'existent pas et je suis
désolé c'est une base de la statistique
et je vous assure que je suis un très
bon méthodologiste donc c'est du
fantasme qu'on vous répète à tour de
bras qui est véhiculé par des gens qui
sont des méthodologies qui ne
comprennent rien à la science la
méthodologie n'est pas de la science
c'est un outil de la science ça n'a rien
que pour cet extrait trois ans après
l'effet semble vous donner raison 16
sociétés savantes en dénoncé je cite le
plus grand TC thérapeutique
thérapeutique sauvage connu à ce jour
sur l'hydroxychloroquine pourquoi a-t-on
autant attendu pourquoi les pouvoirs
publics ont mis aussi longtemps à réagir
je pense qu'il y a une erreur
méthodologique dès le départ je pense
que les gars en particulier au
personnage qui déroult qui s'est
construit ce personnage depuis quelques
années parce que moi je l'ai connu
avance cette personnage il avait même
pas le look qu'on le voit aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il aurait fallu tuer tu es dans
l'oeuf immédiatement les toxiques
chloroquine en décidant un grand essai
clinique
fait par l'État sinon
tous les sens les siens qui étaient
comme je l'ai dit dans cette audition
Diagon 3 ans qui était complètement non
recevable en plus la réponse elle est
incroyable parce que si je poursuis sa
réponse ça veut dire que lorsque vous
avez un médicament à tester ne vous
fatigue pas faire un essai clinique vous
prenez un patient si éventuellement vous
le soigner vous considérez que c'est bon
et vous mettez le médicament sur le
marché je rappelle pour mémoire que les
cycliniques pour la vaccination ARN en
tout cas pour la version Pfizer que je
dont j'avais suivi le développement ça a
été 47500 personnes dans les années
est-ce que c'est à cause du soutien du
président de la République il avait
affiché au début à Didier roult alors je
peux pas je pense qu'on peut pas parler
de soutien réellement pour connaître un
petit peu les affaires en interne si on
peut pas parler de soutien la question
c'est qu'on est tous été on a tous été
totalement surpris par cette pandémie
j'allais dire jusque va être désemparé
et que rien n'était écartable un moment
donné donc il y avait cette cette
pression marseillaise qui montait le
président s'est laissé convaincre
d'aller juger sur pièce j'allais dire de
se déplacée je pense que c'était pas
forcément la meilleure des stratégies
mais c'était une stratégie possible ça a
plutôt servi effectivement à Didier
Raoult qui a pu accrocher cette photo
supplémentaire s'il était besoin de
Didier roult avec un président de la
République alors avant de vous faire
réagir sur l'actualité de la semaine
passons en revue votre biographie
express sous un autre angle Anne-Sophie
mondreau nous dit ce qu'il faut savoir
de vous
cette question
s'adressecription du Gard mais vous ne
savez peut-être pas qu'avant la
politique centrique ce sont des
microscopes et les éprouvettes docteur
en biochimie et pharmacologie c'est que
nous avons affaire à un homme puisque
nous retrouvons un chromosomique le
grand chromosomique et un petit
chromosomique dans les années 90 ce
jeune chercheur participe à une avancée
majeure la découverte du gène de la
masculine son dada rendre la science
accessible à tous il créanime la toute
première école de l'ADN centre de
recherche et de formation Philippe Berta
est aussi l'un des artisans de
l'université de Nîmes où il enseigne
toujours et déjà en 2003 il s'inquiète
du manque d'étudiants dans la recherche
j'espère que nous serons pas en
situation d'importer des ingénieurs
comme nous importons aujourd'hui des
médecins mais le scientifique rêve d'une
autre expérience observez la politique
de près après un premier échec en 2012
se sont tristes décroches en 2017 en
siège à l'Assemblée où ils sont part des
questions de recherche et de
l'innovation favorable au mandat unique
et bien vous savez quoi il change d'avis
et réélu à l'issue d'une campagne serrée
et oui la politique est tout sauf une
science exacte
alors voilà ce qui ressort de de cette
bio de ce profil c'est que vous êtes
plus un scientifique qu'un politique un
peu détaché sur les questions
d'actualité certains de vos adversaires
par le même en raison de ce détachement
d'amateurisme alors ils font référence à
l'envoi tardif de vos comptes de
campagne qui a failli vous coûter votre
dernier élection alors là je cite
François couril votre ex attaché par le
montant
une réaction alors ma réaction c'est
c'est d'abord je suis pour rien à
l'envoi tardif comme vous l'avez défini
parce que des mes comptes de campagne
ont été envoyés à temps
parce que le mandataire financier n'a
pas assumé son travail jusqu'au bout et
je lui ai fait confiance moi jusqu'au
bout j'aurais peut-être pas assumer la
responsabilité
sur l'adresse donc forcément derrière
mais le cachet de la Poste a fait foi
manifestement donc l'affaire a été a été
il me semble fort légitimement et fort
justement close donc sur le côté après
amateurisme détaché moi je travaille et
je travaille voilà monitit c'est je ne
crois qu'à la valeur travail et je n'ai
pas de d'obsession de communication donc
ce qui compte c'est de travailler je
travaille sur le terrain et qui pour moi
aujourd'hui est un terrain élargi à
pratiquement tout le département du Gard
sur les quatre cinq grands dossiers qui
me semblent vraiment fédérateur et
structurant pour le département et puis
à Paris oui j'ai j'ai probablement
repulé à cause de ça ou autre qu'on m'a
beaucoup publicité c'est que je suis
pratiquement le dernier scientifique de
l'Assemblée nationale alors vous ne
comptez pas briguer un nouveau mandat
vous l'avez dit sur d'autres médias
est-ce que ça vaut pour les prochaines
échéances européennes municipales et ce
Édouard Philippe et votre favori pour la
présidentielle de 207 c'est fait
beaucoup de questions alors
effectivement je ne pense pas briguer
d'autres mandats parce que je crois qu'à
un moment donné il faut savoir s'arrêter
en politique je j'ai l'âge que j'ai je
sais l'âge que j'aurai enfin de ce
mandat 67 ans je pense que c'est un âge
raisonnable pour éventuellement espérer
encore vivre une belle tranche de vie
j'ai essayé de séparer ma vie en
différentes tranches et essayer toujours
de faire quelque chose de différent
quant à Édouard Philippe bon on est à 4
ans de l'échéance on voit si on regarde
un petit peu le journaliste
naturellement le président des modem
vous répondez pas aujourd'hui et
naturellement votre chef de partie mon
président du MoDem François Bayrou sera
candidat je ne le vois pas cette déclaré
pour l'instant
on voit effectivement beaucoup de
candidat potentiel sur une ligne de
départ l'enjeu il est pas là aujourd'hui
je n'en souris pas parce que l'enjeu il
est d'essayer à tout prix pour l'avenir
de ce pays de mes concitoyens de
maintenir le pays dans un axe de
démocratie et aujourd'hui c'est la
démocratie qui est en péril et je le
mesure tous les jours à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc la question maintenant
c'est plus forcément une histoire
d'homme ça sera un moment donné une
histoire d'homme ou de femme mais c'est
surtout comment on conserve ce pays dans
un giron démocratique alors dans
l'actualité de la semaine on retiendra
entre autres sujets la crise du logement
dans un récent tweet vous écrivez la
loizanne zéro artificialisation nette
des sols doit désormais pouvoir
assembler l'AMF l'Association des maires
de France le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale pour réduire de 50% la
bétonisation en 10 ans mais quid de
l'impact de cette mesure sur la crise du
logement on pense que la loizanne va
aggraver puisque le foncier devient plus
rare et plus cher alors commençons dès
le départ là le point de départ le point
de départ je vais vous le donner parce
que j'ai passé une semaine un peu là
encore traumatisante à l'Assemblée j'ai
reçu le directeur adjoint du CNRS s'en
charge de ce qu'on appelle les sciences
de l'Univers lui dans son propos c'est
clair le GIEC est gentil et optimiste
j'ai bien dit optimiste et la réalité il
nous a expliqué le ninio bon je vais pas
rentrer dans ces détails là et plutôt
très inquiétant donc aujourd'hui la
prière la priorité c'est est-ce qu'on
veut on le la survie de l'espèce humaine
sur Terre je dois-je dire on en est
peut-être là donc à partir de là il va
falloir faire collectivement des efforts
qui vont être difficiles alors je viens
sur votre question sur la loizanne qui
était une loi qui a été probablement
écrite de façon maladroite en 2021 dans
le cadre du chapitre et de la loi climat
et résilience aujourd'hui cette loi a
été reprise il faut savoir que la France
est le champion européen de la
bétonisation et de l'artificialisation
des sols loin devant tous les autres que
nous avons pu artificialisé en 50 ans
que lors de les 500 dernières années
donc il faut voir comment se respecter
un engagement qui en 2031 on verrait dur
de moitié il faut le faire
intelligemment pour que personne ne soit
Lézé en particulier je pense en disant
ça aux collectivités au territoire aux
petites communes les petites communes
auront toutes le droit à un hectare
voire même au-delà si ce sont des
nouvelles communes aujourd'hui un accord
au contrat de ce que vous avez dit un
accord a été trouvé à travers la voie
des amendements avec le Sénat et avec
l'association des mères de France
aujourd'hui à charge des députés et du
député que je suis de pas mettre en
péril cet équilibre trouvé qui semble
satisfaire en tout cas quasiment tout le
monde en tout cas les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement suite à la
consultation du Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement ont déçu
vous le savez aujourd'hui on Occitanie
c'est moins 40% de vente sur le logement
neuf donc ça c'est pas prioritaire
aujourd'hui alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est le logement pèse pour un peu plus
de 75% d'artificialisation là où les
entreprises l'industrie pèsent pour
4,8%. donc il est clair qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse le logement qu'on a besoin
de logement moi je suis pour pour une
politique prioritaire de reconstruire la
ville sur la ville venait dans ma
commune venez à Nîmes vous verrez le
nombre de quartiers sur lequel on doit
pouvoir effectivement repenser la ville
donc il nous faut du logement il fallait
commencer par se mettre d'accord sur ce
tel loi zan aujourd'hui l'accord il est
là maintenant on va reprendre
effectivement le logement à la lumière
de cette loizane on va sortir
effectivement ce travail va être réalisé
conjointement par les deux ministres
Klein et par Béchu et on va ré-ouvrir ce
dossier là parce que vous avez raison il
nous faut du logement autre actualité
c'est la venue d'Emmanuel Macron à la
base donc aérienne de sécurité civile de
Nîmes garons positionné comme capitale
européenne de la sécurité civile mais
pour en faire une vraie capitale de la
lutte anti-incendie beaucoup plaid pour
une véritable réindustrialisation du
site est-ce qu'on peut rapatrier
vraiment la construction de Canadair en
France
je pense que ça devient nécessaire on
peut pas de toute façon rester
complètement dépendant du Canada puisque
c'est encore là-bas que le président n'a
annoncé que deux canadairs d'ici 2027
alors qu'on sait que les chaînes de
production sont saturées oui absolument
donc ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
trouver un autre site de production moi
je suis dans ce contexte là complètement
le président de notre métropole position
nous une position nous on verra bien si
effectivement on obtient mais on voit
bien aujourd'hui que que la
problématique du feu n'est pas une
problématique purement méditerranéenne
on a eu des feux cette semaine dans les
Vosges Sima mais ma mémoire est bonne on
voit ce qui se passe au Canada donc
aujourd'hui on est obligé d'amplifier
cette production
je crois que la moindre des choses c'est
de se positionner pour être le site de
production ça me paraît quand même
totalement légitime vous l'avez dit
aujourd'hui la base de Garons et le hub
et le point d'entrée du hub européen on
y est encore sur la réindustrialisation
on y est pas encore mais ça devrait
pouvoir se faire on avance sur un autre
sujet santé dont on a parlé cette
semaine la proposition de loi a donc de
40 députés de visant à réguler
l'installation des médecins dans les
déserts médicaux parmi eux 8 députés
d'Occitanie la majorité présidentielle
et le rassemblement national ont empêché
cette loi donc d'être votée pourquoi
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas appliquer aux
jeunes médecins formés avec de l'argent
public le même principe pour leur
premier poste que pour les professeurs
ou les pharmaciens installés là où on en
a besoin alors je vais pas vous laisser
dire que la totalité de la majorité
présidentielle a voté contre le
rassemblement moi je suis majorité il me
semble pas il me semble que je me suis
abstenu et je vais vous dire pourquoi je
me suis abstenu je me suis abstenu parce
que j'ai pas tous les éléments en main
et et pour moi c'est important ce que je
sais par contre c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
pourra toujours augmenter le nombre de
médecins formés on a guère plus de 15%
des médecins que nous formons qui un
jour posent leurs plaques de généraliste
20% choisiront plutôt l’une spécialité
et les autres choisiront quoi ils
choisiront soit le remplacement parce
que finalement on travaille un peu quand
on veut il semble
sans peu de responsabilité soit
effectivement une activité salariée bien
donc aujourd'hui la question c'est
comment on fait pour améliorer ça j'ai
pas la clé j'ai pas la clé j'ai pas les
éléments moi ce que je sais par contre
pour être dans un environnement quand
même professionnel médical c'est que je
vois plus en plus de médecins qui se
déconventionnent qui passent en secteur
2 ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire des
consultations prix libre à 50 euros
grosso modo non remboursé et qui sont
donc la préfiguration d'une médecine à
deux vitesses ou effectivement nous
aurons ceux qui pourront payer les 50
euros sans remboursement qui auront un
médecin et puis les les je dirais une
population plus en difficulté qui ne
pourra pas se payer cet outil là ça me
rappelle des modèles anglo-saxons que
j'ai pas envie de connaître donc poussez
le risque sur la coupe via la coercition
en imposant l'installation à des
endroits précis sans garder ça en ligne
de mire c'est compliqué donc il faut
trouver une solution il faudra aussi
d'un autre côté que nos admis médecins
qui sont quand même pour ultra
qu'on cherche
on essayait effectivement la citation
sur le grand succès il va falloir
trouver mais il faut surtout avoir tous
ces chiffres en tête alors autre sujet
santé cette semaine la pénurie bien sûr
de médicaments en Ardèche Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé la relocalisation de 25
médicaments dont les prochaines semaines
où en est-on aujourd'hui regardez ce
reportage et on en reparle après ça sera
la question qui fâche
dans cette pharmacie de la région
parisienne comme partout en France
certains médicaments souvent basiques
viennent à manquer des
anti-inflammatoires ou du paracétamol
par exemple aujourd'hui il y a
pratiquement pas une ordonnance on ne
dit pas à nos patients attention on a
plus ce produit ça va arriver dans deux
jours veuillez revenir et c'est vrai que
pour les personnes âgées c'est très
embêtant pour elle c'est très
contraignant comment expliquer ces
pénuries alors que la France possède des
usines de conditionnement de paracétamol
le problème c'est que le principe actif
provient à 80% de Chine et d'Inde
la production paracétamol en France on
l'avait en tout cas la question du
principe actif on était capable de le
produire jusqu'au moment où il y a la
délocalisation et là c'est toute
l'histoire de la délocalisation de
l'industrie pharmaceutique les
industriels pour minimiser les coûts de
production on délocaliser la production
alors pour renforcer sa souveraineté la
France va à nouveau produire ce principe
actif dans cette usine de l'Isère encore
en construction donc ici le terrassement
a commencé pour le la future unité de
paracétamol le directeur table sur 15000
tonnes par an c'est 2 à 3 fois le marché
français et pour être plus rentable le
laboratoire a mis en place un nouveau
procédé de production avec une
intensification forte et une
automatisation et une robotisation du
procédé ça nous permet d'avoir des coûts
de fonctionnement bien moindre avec un
nombre de personnels pour être clair
direct bien moins important que la Chine
la production de paracétamol 100%
français devait débuter en 2023 mésal a
été repoussée à 2025 voire 2026
pourquoi la pénurie de médicaments
s'aggrave en France c'est la question
qui fâche de ce dimanche en politique
Christelle Kermel présidente du syndicat
des pharmaciens de l'euro nous a rejoint
bonjour merci d'être là pour échanger
donc avec Philippe Bertha alors donc on
l'a vu dans ce reportage et des annonces
du président de la République d'abord ça
n'engage à rien sur la volonté de
relocaliser c'est une vision à très long
terme est-ce que ce n'est pas un effet
d'annonce déjà c'est un ici c'est un
effet d'annonce c'est un effet d'annonce
qui va coûter cher puisque de mémoire
c'est déjà 160 millions d'euros dans un
premier temps non c'est pas l'effet
d'annonce la question c'est que cette
cette externalisation vers la Chine et
surtout vers l'Inde d'ailleurs de de la
production de nos principes actifs n'est
pas d'abord spécifique à la France c'est
une longue tendance qui s'est mise en
place depuis des décennies de façon
totalement regrettable surtout que moi
j'étais j'avais médité contre surtout
quand on sait la condition dans les
conditions dans lesquelles sont produits
certains antibiotiques par exemple en
Inde on avait pu s'en alerter justement
ça veut pas dire là non plus pénurie
était multipliée par 30 en 10 ans
ensuite sur
complexe et pas monofactorielle c'est
pas uniquement cet effet là de toute
façon il est hors de propos d'imaginer
qu'on puisse rapatrier en France tous
les composés actifs vous avez des
médicaments dans lequel il y en a juste
6000 qui rentre dans la composition le
levier le plus rapide selon vous et le
plus efficace pour sortir de cette
pénurie déjà il y a une liste qui a été
établie de 450 médicaments prioritaires
dont 50 ultra prioritaires donc le sujet
bien compris parce que je suis pas
spécialiste on va travailler d'abord
pour permettre une production et une
autosuffisance ensuite on a aussi un
autre problème qui est en France on a
pris on a pris l'habitude de payer très
peu cher nos médicaments et en plus on a
pris aussi l'habitude de les
surconsommer il suffit de regarder les
chiffres qui sont encore le publier
aujourd'hui sur les antibiotiques pour
s'en convaincre donc en payant très peu
cher les médicaments que vous ne
produirez pas chez vous parce que vous
allez pas produire tous les médicaments
d'abord ils sont pas bien sûr pour la
beaucoup d'entre eux ils sont ils sont
pas français bien il faudrait bien les
payer pour que à partir de là vous soyez
priorisé en termes de distribution
justement je voudrais demander à la
présidente du syndicat des pharmaciens
quel serait l'effet pour vous d'une
augmentation du prix des médicaments
une disponibilité c'est sûr certes
beaucoup plus rapide comme vous l'avez
dit les principes actifs sont
aujourd'hui en Chine et en Inde donc
j'entends ce que dit le président en
disant on va relocaliser la fabrication
en France maintenant sous combien de
temps c'est pas ce qui va nous sauver
pour cet hiver et pour les pénuries de
médicaments qu'on vit actuellement donc
là je pense qu'il faut être honnête avec
la population et on y arrivera pas pour
tout de suite si on augmente demain le
prix des médicaments en France il faut
savoir que forcément les laboratoires
pourront eux aussi augmenter leur les
production vont augmenter donc forcément
comme ils augmenteront leur prix de
vente ils pourront assumer cette
augmentation et pouvoir acheter les
principes actifs plus chers au jour
d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est ça le
problème c'est que les principes actifs
aujourd'hui ils sont vendus dans
certains pays vous parlez de
[Musique]
l'Allemagne par exemple elle n'a pas les
difficultés qu'on a nous il n'y a pas de
pénurie en Allemagne pourquoi parce que
l'Allemagne achète plus cher c'est
matières premières alors est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut considérer la
santé comme une marchandise car c'est
matières premières sont vendues au plus
offrantes
je pense pas qu'on puisse considérer que
le médicament qui ne concerne tous et on
parle là du médicament simple chimique
moi je pourrais parler des biologiques
et des biothérapie ça sera encore un
autre discours vous savez aujourd'hui ça
pèse pour moins de 12% du budget de la
santé le médicament
et vous pouvez regarder tous les projets
de loi de la sécurité sociale et le
prochain va pas tarder à sortir ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon le pffss à chaque
fois qu'il y a une économie à faire très
clairement c'était la problématique des
hôpitaux qui étaient prioritaires sur le
pdfss précédent 2023 où est pris
l'argent est pris sur l'enveloppe
médicament donc cet enveloppe médicament
elle est en souffrance elle est
totalement insuffisante en regard des
problèmes de chimiques qu'on a
aujourd'hui et des pénuries et on
regarde encore plus à mes yeux mais
je crois qu'on en avait parlé c'est
effectivement comment on va payer la
médecine personnalisée de demain avec
cette enveloppe là alors est-ce que à
l'origine de cette pénurie il n'y a pas
aussi la toute-puissance de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française qui profite
aujourd'hui de son quasi monopole et des
aides publiques avec notamment la
détention de brevet et qui a fait le
choix de délocaliser la production
comment est-ce qu'on coule comment
l'État peut
[Musique]
agiral disons non les industriels mais
bien sûr les torts sont partagés je
pense que il y a il y a des marges bon
après il y a le problème du générique il
y a tous ces problèmes c'est l'état de
réguler tout ça
veulent un pôle un pôle national du
médicament dont je garantis
effectivement que là par contre en terme
de pénurie on serait vraiment grande
difficulté que l'État a son mot à dire
c'est clair le mode il a des outils pour
ça il a des incitations je pars parler
du crédit impôt recherche par les il y a
beaucoup d'outils effectivement
financiers qui viennent derrière ou
l'État doit avoir son mot à dire
effectivement sur cette analyse vous la
partagez
je vais peut-être pas être aussi pointu
que Monsieur donc sur le sujet alors je
vais pas autre question sur cette
pénurie au jour le jour quel est
l'impact sur votre activité déjà et
est-ce que vous considérez qu'une vente
je dirais à l'unité des médicaments
comme ça se fait dans certains pays avec
un conditionnement minimum je sais cela
vous fait sourire mais pour être plus
écologique est-ce que cela pourrait être
une réponse ponctuelle à la situation
ponctuelle absolument pas absolument pas
aujourd'hui les médicaments
sont fabriqués avec des boîtages qui
correspondent à une durée de traitement
donc dire qu'on va faire de la
délivrance à l'unité ça va encore on va
dire augmenter la charge de travail du
pharmacien d'officine et ça assurera je
vais dire que des problèmes d'insécurité
la menteuse parce que des boîtes de
médicaments dont leur boîte à pharmacie
donc on se retrouve avec des comprimés
en vrac sans savoir la date de
péremption sans le numéro de le haut
comment on va faire quand tu auras des
retraits de l'eau enfin il y a plein de
questions quand même qui se posent et
des questions surtout de sécurité quand
même sanitaire là ça me pose quand même
un gros problème Liberta sur cette
question non moi je vais l'élargir cette
question moi je vais appeler à tout à
chacun aussi un petit peu à la raison je
crois qu'on a on a un vrai problème dans
la relation de consommation dans ce que
nous avons fait de la médecine dans ce
pays c'est-à-dire une espèce de droite
consommation sans aucun regard du coup
puisqu'on paye pas on a une carte Vitale
tout va bien quand vous quittez
l'hôpital ou la clinique on vous laisse
pas une facture qui est au moins pour le
mérite non pas que vous la payer mais
que de vous rendre compte du coup et
aujourd'hui on est devenu des ultras
consommateurs moi j'ai des généraliste
dans mon environnement qui sont prêts à
venir dire ici que 60 à 70% des
consultations qu'ils font au quotidien
n'ont pas vraiment lieu d'être donc on a
aussi un problème d'éducation à la santé
et un problème majeur et je pense il
faut que ça s'accélère de prévention
santé merci on va poursuivre avec votre
mode la fin le mot de la fin que vous
avez choisi c'est un petit peu votre je
dirais spécialisation les maladies
aujourd'hui 3 millions de personnes sont
atteintes plus de 7000 maladies rares
identifiées 75% des patients sont
atteints des patients atteints sans des
enfants alors pourquoi est-ce que vous
pensez que le politique ne prend pas
assez au sérieux les enjeux liés aux
maladies déjà parce que je pense qu'il a
encore du mal à comprendre ce que c'est
qu'une maladie rare et que le politique
souvent il s'arrête à l'adjectif quand
il voit l'adjectif rare il se dit bon
c'est pas une priorité puisque c'est
rare donc mais vous l'avez rappelé c'est
une famille sur 20 qui est concernée et
je dirais à minima puisque ce sont on
parle là quand on dit 3 millions
d'enfants concernés c'est ce qui sont
diagnostiqués et on a beaucoup qui sont
en errance diagnostic et qui ne le sont
pas donc je je fais tout pour que le
politique prenne ça comme une priorité
pourquoi parce que les maladies rares
posent toutes les questions de la santé
de demain avant les autres c'est-à-dire
la problématique du diagnostic est-ce
qu'on va sur la génétique ou est-ce que
nous ne vont pas on n'y va pas et dans
ce pays forcer de constater qu'on a peur
de la génétique ce qui est assez
étonnant même que lorsqu'on parle de
santé elle pose la question plus globale
de la médecine de demain parce que
aujourd'hui je vais vous prendre un peu
prendre un exemple qui s'appelle une
pathologie terrible qui s'appelle
lamotrophie spinale on a une
cinquantaine d'enfants à traiter par an
sur cette pathologie qui fait partie
17000 pathologies on est capable que
dans traiter 5 pourquoi pas parce que
c'est cher alors dans ce domaine vous
parlez de l'explosion des biothérapies
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui quand on va
vous soigner les biothérapies
aujourd'hui sont majoritaires par
rapport à ce qu'on appelle les chimiques
avant c'est quoi une biothérapie ça
s'appelle la thérapie génique 2000
essais en cours à travers le monde donc
ça va exploser ça s'appelle la thérapie
cellulaire ça s'appelle l'immunothérapie
ça concerne en particulier nos concerts
nos tumeurs et donc c'est et ça va
s'appeler aussi la vaccination
personnalisée qui est en cours de
développement donc c'est là où ça se
joue ce sont des perspectives magiques
ma génération peut-être qu'on est un peu
tard pour moi mais en tout cas je vois
ce qui se passe à travers le monde la
question c'est que toutes ces questions
posées par les maladies rares en
première ligne implique des réponses
très complexe mais qui va falloir oser
c'est juste revisiter complètement notre
façon d'évaluer un médicament on en a
parlé au départ et aussi réfléchir à un
modèle économique pour ce médicament
parce qu'il va coûter cher mais la
question qu'il faut poser est-ce que ça
coûte si cher que ça finalement est-ce
que le patient traité il va peut-être
coûter cher mais il faudrait un jour
être capable de le comparer aux patients
pas traités qui va vivre d'abord une vie
infernale et souvent une vie qui va mal
se terminer qui va avoir un parcours de
soin absolument insensé qui va donc
coûter très cher à la société soit sur
plusieurs années est-ce que l'effort
d'investissement de la recherche doit se
porter sur les maladies rares qui
concernent malgré tout moins de
personnes que sur la recherche sur des
médicaments ou le développement la
production de médicaments je vais pas
faire de je vais pas poser une
discipline à une autre il faut
aujourd'hui que la recherche en santé
deviennent une grande priorité nationale
je répète que la recherche en France est
toujours coincée à 2,2% du PIB et nous
attendons mieux merci je rappelle que
vous êtes aussi président du groupe donc
étude maladie rare à l'Assemblée
nationale merci de nous avoir suivis
merci à nos invités bon dimanche à vous
c'était votre dimanche en politique vous
pouvez revoir cette émission sur
france.tv bon dimanche
[Musique]